ah my Romeo and Juliet right
star-crossed lovers I got it hey guys
curfew let's go good luck
they're lying it's been like this all
summer it's romantic
it's gross it's [ __ ] like we just
pretend she knows I'm lying I don't even
understand hey guys I'm almost set up
here I had no choice Lucas I really had
no choice I just wish you consulted me
there's more to life than stupid Boise
now guys I'm still here
guys please play D&D now no is this a
nice surprise what are you doing here I
dumped your ass
[Music]
guys it's ready well not right now they
broke up with you what else is there to
talk about sons yeah we're trying to
solve the great mystery of the female
species dude you can smell the nacho
cheese now can we play D&D no I'm doing
myself what are you doing
yeah will you turn on the music please
address me by my full name what my full
name oh okay we'll the wise can you
please turn down the music I have seen
into the future and I've seen that today
is a new day a day three of girls what
is happening right now the juju bites
your let's cheers ah seven points of
damage
oh no my arm Lucas with my arm no it's a
distraction a trap
do not answer
no what's finished for real how much
longer is the camp just forget it Mike
no you want to keep playing right yeah
totally we'll just call the girls
afterwards I said forget it Mike okay
we're just not in the mood right now
yeah Mike that's the problem you guys
are never in the mood anymore
you're ruining our party that's not true
really
where's Dustin right now see you don't
know and you don't even care and
obviously he doesn't either and I don't
blame him seriously welcome to my world